no no no no no no no no no listen to
that song while I was on a run this
morning to the park hmm yeah
starwars marriage story that's what we
needed between kylo Ren and raise star
wars the clone wars official trailer
shows coming back for a final 12
episodes season I actually started this
show a few weeks ago I'm only on Episode
four then I had a whole bunch of people
especially at our patreon page go you're
not watching it in chronological order
they actually released it in a weird
order so here is the list so I kind of
list how to watch it in chronological
order I'm like wait a minute you're
gonna be watching this in the way it was
released now I'm confused on how to
approach this for some reason stopping
my flow with watching the show made me
go I'm gonna put this on hold so comment
below and confuse us even more as to
what order these episodes should be
watched so my goal with watching this
trailer right now is to remote of eight
myself to get him back into watching
this show so sorry movie trivia Schmo
down I'm opting out now don't have time
to catch up on movies I have to catch up
on Star Wars the Clone Wars show to keep
up a lore
[Music]
very cool a remake window
Oh Sam Witwer from the movie tributes
that's right
Wow the animation list
[Music]
[Music]
the clams
feelings
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
wait a minute good golly Wow
[Music]
weight has led to this group the
animation looks great
was way it was Pat had me pregnant there
we got to go back we gotta go look have
me see look I mean she's clearly had a
baby bump right
who knows maybe it was just a really
distorted hologram no oh
comments are turned off on this video I
wonder why I don't know I mean it's a
pretty good trailer I mean that's that's
a big deal if she's pregnant though
because the clone wars from my
understanding is just supposed to take
place between episode 2 and episode 3
you're watching the Clone Wars filling
in the gap and Revenge of the Sith
Anakin found out Padme was pregnant
sheet there's a whole scene where she
tells him so if he's talking to a
hologram of her and she's holding her
baby bump
that was mean he already knows that
she's pregnant so does this mean this
season every gonna see like order 66
take place are we gonna see some
episodes that'll take place during
episode 3 yeah we pretty cool that's
something I didn't expect or that's just
a mislead in the animation the Russo
brothers stepped in and said let's tweak
that animation just to confuse some
people or what we're doing it's a flash
forward from the last five minutes of
the final episode yeah I'm just going
through a couple sentimental
heart-stirring colors after all that
action gotta tie it into Luke and Leia
and all that stuff well no now it's
making me wonder if we'll see Darth
Vader actually appear in this one it's
possible cuz I'll say as a loyal viewer
of the Clone Wars after only being four
episodes in I'm already like this
version of Anakin I have much prefer
over the version that we that we got in
the movies just seems like better
written personality and his leadership
skills with us so good are very much
present I don't see I haven't seen a
single episode I've seen trailers all
you need no you're right I mean the
animation here I thought looked amazing
but as an outsider to the show I mean
this definitely entices me especially in
the wake of the less satisfying recent
Star Wars things at the cinema this
actually pulls me in that much further
to the world the action looks
spectacular just the breadth of the
characters looks really interesting and
this looks like it actually holds a good
amount of dramatic weight perhaps more
so than some recent movie so that's yeah
I mean I've always heard that the Clone
Wars is terrific this is perhaps the
most exciting glimpse of that I've had
so far besides that scene we reacted to
a little while back that action sequence
is pretty pretty rad and the way they
pitched this trailer made it look like
that most of the focus will be on ahsoka
tano and Darth Maul protagonist
antagonist as the central focus of the
show would of course cutting in between
every one of that man I just can't get
over the fact that we might actually get
to see some order 66 and all that going
on like things within that's something I
didn't expect
um Jedi slaughter all the video things
Disney's lesson a sacar dari in this one
yeah according to the description here
you're saying it's only going to be 12
episodes usually when shows get you know
a big fan base they tend to sharpen up
the animation there was some money in
that budget and it really looks like
they've really amped up the quality here
it's pretty much like a cinematic
quality of animation it's just funny to
me how this show has really just taken
off as one of the best things to come
out of Star Wars because the Clone Wars
movie I saw that Clone Wars movie when
it first came out really did not like it
and I'm not alone on that it's not a
very good movie so I never had interest
in watching the show and it was until
the years later where I heard how
amazing this show is and so now that
it's on Disney plus and that we have
Disney plus I'm slowly but surely
watching and I guess I'll watch it in
the chronological aren't you comment in
the comment boxes just watch it in the
order that it was released or should I
actually go through the list and watch
it in chronological order the
chronological ones just seems a lot more
appealing than me well yeah I mean
you'll get the story arguably in the
sequence it was meant to play out in
yeah then somebody's you know airing the
schedule which used to happen a lot more
I feel like I used to hear that from my
dad about shows he was on his like I
know they're airing these episodes out
of orders a certain parts of the
continuity aren't gonna make sense until
next week
I don't know that hard are you sure
you're airing I don't know it's a
production thing or if the studio just
says hey we want to put this one out
this week for our ratings because we've
got some other programming it'll work
well with but now that is you know
Disney Plus that's not a concern Jon
dad grew up in the 1940s by the way
that's correct the talkies we're gonna
put these pictures in color now we're
border and the theaters we're gonna put
part three out first and you do get a
glimpse abit of one of the the clones I
don't know if he's the main character
and not I am sorry of character talking
about how he's conflicted about the war
and that's something I really like that
the show it does upon its introduction
right away is humanizing the clones
really making them you know characters
with emotion and depth that as opposed
to people in pre stormtrooper outfits I
better start playing catch-up I got I
got a month you can do it I believe I
will you'll see probably wild beaches
I'm gonna casually watch this and then
by the end of the year I'll let you know
my thoughts on the Clone Wars maybe I'll
do a video called I finally watched all
the Clone Wars that's a great title I
mean this experience is a new for me to
watch trailers for the late seasons and
Ango and actually watch the whole show
they've been did it with God and now I'm
almost done with Gotham alright guys
well are you excited for Star Wars the
Clone Wars what are your theories and
thoughts on this trailer leave a comment
down below what's the main takeaway I'm
supposed to have on this trailer the
thing you wanted a comment on the Star
Wars page but they won't let you do it
subscribe to the real rejects this is
not a kylo Ren thing but that's the
closest thing we got to a kylo Ren and
before we wrap this up I'd like to end
this with a page for the day shout out
to a Delia Chamberlain now Delia hat is
a huge Star Wars fan major Star Wars fan
unfortunately because of the holidays
and having to be with family she had to
catch rise of Skywalker late got things
spoil for her she thought she wasn't
gonna like it ended up walking out of it
having enjoyed it she sees the flaws but
overall like subtle she even got some
really cool gifts this Christmas one of
them being a Star Wars book so delia
can't wait to hear your thoughts and
what you think of the Clone Wars and she
says
we need a kylo Ren ants
it sounds exactly like a doozy Hey yeah
we need a kylo hey you need to get one
of those masks you know Delia get on
that send my man's a kylo Ren voice
changing mask no no no save your money
no but that's my Foreman Oh
Adelia I hope you have a kick-ass here
this 2020 I know you got a new writing
books so I expect more writing from you
to come sincerely thank you so much for
being a part of our page around page you
made a major impact in my life and mine
yeah but more me cuz I talk with you
more that's just not like a favoritism
thing it's just the way it goes is
circumstantial thing exactly it's
cyclical nope didn't use that right in a
sense I mean you